And his brother and went to feed
their father's flock and shuck him.
So they took off and
Israel said unto Joseph,
do you know what the I brethren feed
the flock and check them common,
I will send thee unto him.
And he said he had and he said to him,
here,
up here on mine,
and when they saw him afar off,
even before he came near onto them,
they conspired against him to slay him.
Rough people act then,
right?
This is,
this sort of thing is
happening quite frequently.
Um,
and they said to one another,
behold the dreamer cometh.
Come now,
therefore let us slay him,
cast him into some pit and we will say
some evil beast has devoured him and we
shall see what becomes of his dreams.
So there's an echo of the Kate
enables story there obviously.
You know what I mean?
It's not quite as clear because in the
Kate enables store able is clearly just
doing well.
And here you can't quite get a
handle on Joseph's character.
You can't tell if he is actually the
elect or if he's just a spoiled Brat with
delusions of grandeur.
You know,
and,
but it doesn't matter because his
brothers are so irritated at his,
the fact that he's favored and perhaps
even the fact that he might be someone
destined for,
for something special,
that they find it perfectly
reasonable to destroy that.
And it's so hard.
It's so interesting how often that
motif of pulling down an ideal manifest
itself in these old stories,
right?
It's,
it's,
the pattern is established
in the Cain and Abel Story.
It just repeats and repeats and repeats.
And I think that's dead true.
I think it just repeats all the time,
is that people are annoyed about
how tragic their lives are.
They're annoyed that they're subject
to malevolence and they're annoyed that
they're not doing as well
as other people are doing.
And that makes them,
that puts them exactly
into this state of mind.
Now,
maybe with modern people,
if you're going to kill someone because
you're resentful as a modern person,
you don't generally slay them
and throw them into a pit.
You know,
what you do is you just killed
them slowly over a few decades.
And it isn't obvious to
me that that's any better.
So I've seen plenty of married
couples who were in that situation.
It's like,
it's like,
Whoa,
there,
this Mitch Hedberg,
he used to complain
about turtleneck phase.
It was like being strangled
by a really weak midget,
and
it's probably really
politically incorrect joke,
but it's a funny joke.
So,
uh,
and then you see,
you see relationships that are like that.
It's like each person has their hands
around the neck of the other person,
but they don't have enough
courage to actually to squeeze it.
Just put enough pressure on to s
cut the circulation off a tiny bit.
So the person just gets like
a die over 30 year period.
Something like that.